hurricane Joaquin is now forecast to
miss the United States with a storm
track that now takes it east into the
Atlantic Ocean just take a look at my
Bloomberg terminal this is our be map
function it shows the latest predicted
path of the hurricane and but this does
not mean that there won't be an economic
effect from the storm share prices of
storm sensitive stocks rose and fell as
the tide did with the changing forecast
Bloomberg's Ramey inocencio has been
looking into this and joins me now for
more hey there pim yeah you know it's
interesting that there's always a
tradable moments in anything and in this
case it's a hurricane so investors who
are storm Watchers can trade or have
traded in fact on stocks that are
sensitive to the weather so in this case
home improvement stores energy storage
companies and on the flip side actually
insurers actually saw some effects from
hurricane Joaquin even though it didn't
it is so for example I want to take a
look at the Home Depot and Lowe's like
people stocking up on everything and
maybe getting plywood in order to put up
against windows and so on exactly so in
preparation for that a lot of people
were thinking oh you know what we need
to just get ready just in case so since
sep tember 30 and over the past few days
we did see a price rise right here
you're seeing a week a one week so it's
not accurately showing it but if you
just look it from sep tember 30 over the
next two days it has risen and
interestingly looking at some what
happened with hurricane sandy a few
weeks ago Home Depot actually got nearly
three hundred million dollars in a sales
bump in the fourth quarter of 2012 and
the 1st quarter of 2013 something
similar for lows they saw a point
through percentage basis point bump into
their quarter revenue for that same time
frame another thing to talk about is
energy storage companies of course when
the lights go out what are you gonna
need you might need power somehow power
and flashlights and so similar here you
can see that energizer holdings of
course a maker of batteries from sep
tember 30 also rose over the next few
days seeing that bump there
interestingly also passes precedents
sandy contributed about an 18 million
dollar bumper about a 1 percent bump to
energizer sales revenues when the storm
hit during that time a couple years
go all rights he got home depot lowes as
well as energizer right any other second
you mentioned insurance companies as
well yeah that's right insurers as the
storm got closer actually fell we
started seeing that actually happening
last Thursday through Friday and looking
at allstate right now even from sep
tember 29 you can see that fall over the
last three days they're the one week
it's down by nearly three percent and
interestingly all state lost 1.1 billion
dollars from Sandy so as you can expect
as a storm gets closer everyone gets a
little bit more nervous saying oh no are
the insurer's going to take it
interestingly I talked with I talked
with bienz Brian Sullivan up in Boston I
need to get this at fifteen point seven
trillion dollars of property all along
the coast is exposed and at potential
risk of storms you also have because
they have flooding I mean flood exactly
it doesn't have to be the money image
wind shear it doesn't need to be that
close and interestingly I just have one
final thing I want to share take a look
at this over the past 30 years the top
three states to have had the most losses
by insurance we're Florida which you can
sort of understand Texas of course also
there but interesting in New York nine
percent and that's about forty three
billion dollars there and it surprised
me when I saw that because we are so far
north but all told over the last 30
years get this more almost half a
trillion dollars has been incurred in
terms of losses because of storms that
hit the country